edouard philippe restera-t-il premier
ministre à quoi ressemblera le futur
gouvernement et surtout pour quel projet
au lendemain d'un scrutin calamiteux
pour la république en marche
là ma chronique est en ébullition
emmanuel macron veut tout changer
le canard enchaîné révèle dans son
édition du 1er juillet que le chef de
l'état n'aurait pas caché sa déception
dimanche soir en découvrant la déroute
de ses candidats le président de la
république aurait même déclaré
rien ne sert de pleurer mais force est
de constater qu'après trois ans
d'exercice
nous avons été incapables de nous
implanter localement
lucide le chef de l'état aurait toujours
selon le palmipède évoqué une raclée
pire que les prévisions des instituts de
sondage
il ne s'agit donc plus de savoir s'il y
aura un remaniement mais plutôt quand
celui ci aura lieu et vers quels hommes
et femmes le président pourrait bien se
tourner pour conjurer le sort
emmanuel macron qui doit donner un
nouveau souffle à son action sera sans
doute tenté de verdir son équipe après
la vague écologiste qui a déferlé dans
les grandes villes du pays
ce remaniement devrait connaître un
premier dénouement d'ici là la fin de la
semaine avec la démission d'edouard
philippe ce proche d'alain juppé marqué
à droite
inflexible sur la réforme des retraites
n'est pas réputé pour ses convictions
écologiques
il serait donc peu à même d'incarner le
virage vert auquel on peut s'attendre
pour cette fin de quinquennat
en cas de confirmation du départ
d'edouard philippe plusieurs noms ont
circulé très tôt pour récupérer matignon
jean yves le drian actuel ministre des
affaires étrangères ou encore bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie ces
derniers jours un autre nom est venu
s'ajouter à la liste des prétendants
celui de florence parly l'actuel
ministre de la défense sa nomination
aurait un double intérêt pour le chef de
l'état
c'est une ancienne du parti socialiste
et elle deviendrait la première femme à
accéder à ce poste 29 ans après edith
cresson
c'est surtout parmi les portefeuilles
dits régaliens que l'avenir semble
incertain
la garde des sceaux nicole belloubet
paraît condamné les proches du président
l'accusent d'avoir cassé le lien avec
les professions du droit
idem pour son collègue de l'intérieur
christophe castaner plus que jamais
fragilisé par le move
mon contre les violences policières et
le rejet qu'il inspire désormais à ses
troupes une autre proche des manuels
macron serait sur la sellette six bêtes
ndiaye porte parole du gouvernement qui
a enchaîné déclarations hasardeuses et
couacs notamment lors de la crise du
coronavirus emmanuel macron se retrouve
donc face à un véritable casse tête
le contexte de crise économique et
sociale ainsi que la percée écologiste
devrait pousser le président a donné un
coup de barre à gauche mais il doit
également penser à récompenser ses
alliés du modem et d'agir sans lesquels
la majorité perdrait son influence au
parlement
si l'écologie devrait être le maître mot
de ce remaniement après la séquence que
nous venons de vivre les membres du
parti europe ecologie les verts dopés
par leur triomphe électoral ont déjà
fait savoir qu'ils refuseraient de
participer au nouveau gouvernement